The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Several times in our
course up until now,
we have referred to linearity.
We referred to it when
we talked about systems
of linear equations.
We referred to it when
we talked about systems
of linear differential
equations.
We referred to it when we
talked about Laplace transforms.
We referred to it when
we were mapping the xy
plane into the uv plane and
talking about differentials.
And now, what we'd like
to do in today's lesson
is to show how the general
concept of a vector space
gives us a very nice
vehicle to tie together
all of these different
applications of linearity.
In fact, today's
lesson is called
"Linear Transformations."
And by way of a very
quick definition,
one which I will not bother
motivating because we've
seen the definition on many,
many different occasions.
All we're doing now
is formalizing it.
Let's suppose I have two vector
spaces, V and W, and a mapping
f that carries V
into W. Remember,
these vector spaces
are in particular sets.
And we've talked about functions
that map sets into sets.
Now we're mapping
a set into a set
where the set has a structure,
the structure of a vector
space.
And what we're saying is that
a function that maps a vector
space V into a vector space W is
called a linear transformation
if, given any linear combination
of elements in the domain,
say C1 alpha 1 plus C2
alpha 2, where C1 and C2 are
real numbers, and alpha 1
and alpha 2 are vectors in V,
if f of that is C1 f of alpha
1 plus C2 f of alpha 2--
the same linearity definition
that we've had in the past.
And again, if this is
hard for you to visualize,
think in terms of pictures.
Think of V as, for example,
being the xy plane.
Think of W as
denoting the uv plane.
And we're mapping the xy
plane, say, into the uv plane.
Not all such mappings
will be linear.
We studied that when we
talked about linear systems
of equations.
Now, what we would
like to do now
is to show how many
of the properties
of linearity that
we've used in the past
are immediate consequences of
this particular definition.
Well, let's take a look at
some of the consequences.
The first thing I
claim is that if f
is a linear transformation,
it must map the 0 element of V
into the 0 element of W. In
other words, f acting on 0 maps
it into 0.
And the easiest
way to prove that
is to notice that since
0 is equal to 0 plus 0,
by that property, f of 0 is
certainly the same as f of 0
plus 0.
And now by linearity, f of 0
plus 0 is f of 0 plus f of 0.
And now, comparing
this with this,
remember, these are vectors,
the cancellation rule
applies for vectors.
We then obtain that f of 0 is 0.
And by the way, this is a
rather interesting subtlety
that comes up.
Remember when we talked about
linear equations in the plane?
In other words, f of
x equals mx plus b.
That is not the same as
a linear transformation.
In fact, let me just see
if I can scribble something
in over here.
Look at this.
Suppose I have that f of
x is equal to mx plus b.
See, that's the equation
of a straight line.
What is f of 0?
If f of x is mx plus b, if I
replace x by 0, I get what?
0 times m, which is 0, plus b.
And therefore, for f to
be a linear transformation
according to our definition,
this must equal 0.
And therefore, what this means
is that b itself must equal 0.
In other words,
even though we think
of a straight line
as being linear,
to represent a linear
transformation,
the straight line must
pass through the origin.
But I don't want to
harp on that now.
I want to let that
go for the exercises
because I'm afraid, again, if we
spend too much time on details,
you will fail to get
the overall picture.
But at any rate, one property
of a linear transformation
is that it maps the 0
vector into the 0 vector.
Now, of course, other vectors
may be mapped into the 0 vector
as well.
I mean, we'll talk about that
in more detail in the form
of a review, in fact, later on.
But for the time
being, let me show you
the next property of
linear transformations
that are very important.
And that is that
if V1 and V2 are
mapped into 0 by the
linear transformation f,
then any linear
combination of V1 and V2
is also mapped into 0.
And by the way,
you may think when
I say this-- this
may ring a bell
and remind you of
what we were doing
when we talked about homogeneous
linear differential equations.
And the interesting
point is that this
is exactly the same as
what we were doing there,
only now, we're not
restricted to be dealing only
with linear
differential equations.
This is now any linear
transformation from one vector
space into another.
And the proof goes
exactly the way
it did in the linear
differential equation case.
Namely, given f
of C1V1 plus C2V2,
we certainly know that
by linearity, that
C1 f of V1 plus C2 f of V2.
But given that f of V1
is 0, and f of V2 is 0,
certainly, this then
becomes 0, which
is what we wanted to show.
In other words, if you have
a linear transformation,
the set of elements that are
mapped into the 0 element
are more than a set.
They are themselves a vector
space, a subspace of V,
a subspace of the domain of f.
Because why?
Any linear combinations of
elements mapped into 0 by f is
itself-- any linear
combination is itself--
mapped into f.
In other words,
let's define n to be
the set of all elements eta
in V, such that f of eta is 0.
And that space is called
the null space of f.
It's a subspace of
the domain of fV.
And all we're saying is
by our previous remark,
if two elements belong to
n, their sum belongs to n,
and any scalar multiple of an
element in n also belongs to n.
So n is indeed a subspace of V.
It's a very important subspace.
It's called the null space.
And one of things
about the null space--
and by the way, many people
get confused by this name.
They say the null space, they
think of "null" as being empty,
nothing.
And they say that null
space has nothing in it.
No.
Think of it in terms
of the mapping.
The null space is
part of a domain.
And what it is-- it's
that part of the domain
that's mapped into the
0 element of the image.
You see?
It is not nothing.
It's the set of all elements
that are mapped into 0.
And what we're saying
is that that subspace
is enough to determine
the entire mapping.
Let me show what I mean
by that abstractly.
I claim that n determines
the image of f.
Namely, I claim that if I
know that f of alpha equals f
of beta, and f is a
linear transformation,
alpha and beta cannot be very
random elements of V. In fact,
what I claim is that the
difference between alpha
and beta must be an element
of the null space n.
Or another way of
saying that, I claim
that alpha has the form
beta plus eta, where eta is
an element of the null space n.
And again, this may ring
a familiar bell for you
when you think in terms
of linear differential
equations and the like,
where we essentially
saw that any two solutions
of a differential equation,
that their difference
was a solution
of the homogeneous linear
differential equation.
But again, I don't want
to dwell on that now.
I want to talk on the most
abstract version of this.
How do I know that this is true?
Well, look at it.
What does it mean to say that
f of alpha equals f of beta?
It means that f of alpha
minus f of beta is 0.
But by linearity, f of
alpha minus f of beta
is the same as f of
alpha minus beta.
Therefore, the fact that f
of alpha minus f of beta is 0
says that f of alpha
minus beta is 0.
By definition of
the null space n,
the fact that alpha minus
beta is mapped into 0
means that alpha minus
beta belongs to n.
And that's the same
as saying what?
That alpha minus beta
is some element in n.
Or alpha is beta plus
some element in n--
same thing as we asserted.
By the way, another
interesting way
of seeing one to oneness
of a linear transformation
is that since the only way
that two elements can have
the same image is
for one of them
to equal the other plus
something that belongs to n,
the only way we can be
sure that alpha equals
beta is if this
element must be 0.
You see, alpha
equals beta plus 0.
We'll say that
alpha equals beta.
So in particular, if a linear
transformation is one to one,
the null space must
consist of 0 alone.
And conversely, if the null
space consists of 0 alone,
the linear
transformation is 1 to 1.
Notice, by the
way, the null space
can never be empty because
by our first property,
we show that the 0 vector
is always mapped into 0.
So at least the 0 vector
belongs to the null space.
If other vectors belong
to the null space,
the linear transformation
will not be 1 to 1.
If 0 is the only vector that
belongs to the null space of f,
then the linear
transformation will be 1 to 1.
Now, I think the time
has come to illustrate
some of these remarks in
terms of concrete examples.
For my first
example, let's recall
that the mapping that maps
functions into their derivative
is a well-defined linear
transformation on the set
of differentiable functions.
Remember, the
derivative of a sum
is the sum of the derivatives.
The derivative of a
scalar times a function
is a scalar times the
derivative of the function.
In other words,
then, the mapping D,
which maps a function into its
derivative, is a vector space.
It's a linear transformation
from one vector
space to another.
In particular, what does
the null space look like?
The null space of
D must be what?
All functions f, such
that D maps f into 0.
The only way that D of f
can be 0 is if f prime is 0.
But f prime being identically
0 is the same as saying
f equals a constant.
Therefore, the null
space in this case
is the set of all constants.
Notice, by the
way, the null space
does not consist of 0 alone.
It consists of infinitely
many numbers, namely
all the constants.
By the way, that shouldn't
be too surprising
because after all, the
derivative is not a one to one
mapping of
differentiable functions
into the set of functions.
Namely, two different functions
can have the same derivative.
In fact, what is the property?
For D of f to equal D of g,
it's necessary and sufficient
that f and g differ
by a constant.
And notice that that's the same
as saying what we said before,
that for two elements
to have the same image
under a linear
transformation, they
must differ by, at most, an
element in the null space.
That's exactly what happens
in this particular example.
As a second example,
let's go back
to our study of linear
differential equations.
We wanted to find the solution
of the equation L of y
equals f of x.
Notice that L is a linear
transformation mapping
functions into functions.
The interesting
point was, you may
recall, that we emphasized
the homogeneous equation,
where the right-hand
side was replaced by 0.
Notice that the null
space of the mapping L--
see, the null space--
namely what?
All functions y that map
into 0 with respect to L.
That means what?
L of y is 0.
Well, the null
space is just what?
The solution set
of L of y equals 0.
That's just the
homogeneous equation.
And to show you what
we mean by this,
notice what the general theory
was for linear differential
equations.
Namely, the general solution
was the homogeneous solution
plus a particular
solution, noticing
that for the
homogeneous solution,
it was characterized
by the fact that it
belonged to the null space.
Namely, L of y sub h was 0.
The particular solution was
just anything in the space,
namely L of yp equals f of
x, same as we have over here.
And so that structure for
linear differential equations
was not an exception, but
rather one concrete illustration
of what a really a
transformation means
in an abstract vector space.
As a third and final
and more visual example,
let's go back to mapping the
xy plane into the uv plane.
Let's suppose I take the
mapping u equals x plus y,
v equals 2x plus 2y.
And notice, by the
way, that's just
another way of saying
v equals twice u.
The induced function
is the one that
carries x comma
y in the xy plane
into u comma v in the uv plane,
so my induced function f bar
is the one that maps x comma y
into x plus y comma 2x plus 2y.
w
And you can look at x comma
y as being the vector xi
plus yj in the xy plane.
Or you can look at it as
being the point x comma
y in the xy plane.
I don't care which
interpretation
you want to use there.
But the point is,
what we now would
like to know in terms
of the null space
is what points x comma
y are mapped into 0,
0 in the uv plane under
the mapping f bar?
Or in terms of
vectors, what vectors
xi plus yj are mapped into the 0
vector under the mapping f bar?
Well, notice that for this
to be 0, we must have what?
That both components are 0.
That means that x plus y must
be 0 and that 2x plus 2y is 0.
But of course, that's the
same as this condition.
In other words, f bar of x
comma y is 0, meaning what?
It's mapped into the origin
if and only if x plus y is 0.
In other words, the
null space of f bar
is the set of all points
in the plane x comma y
for which x plus y equals 0.
Or again, if you want to
state this vectorially,
it's all vectors xi
plus yj in the xy
plane, for which x plus y is 0.
And what this means
pictorially is this.
Notice that the set n is
nothing more than what we
call the line y equals minus x.
In the set of all points x comma
y, such as x plus y equals 0,
is the same as the set
of all points x comma y,
such that y equals minus x.
y equals minus x, or
x plus y equals 0,
is a straight line
through the origin.
Notice again that key point.
f of 0 must be 0 for a
linear transformation.
If that line didn't
pass through the origin,
the mapping wouldn't be linear.
Now, notice, by the way,
if I come back here,
the mapping defined
by u and v maps
the xy plane into the
single line v equals 2u.
In other words, the
xy plane is mapped
into the line v equals 2u.
And the entire line
x plus y equals 0
is mapped into the
origin over here.
In other words, the null
space here is an entire line.
What line is it?
It's the line x plus y equals 0.
Why is it called the null space?
It's called the null space
not because it has no points,
but rather because its image
consists of the single point
0 in the uv plane.
And by the way, notice again
the parallelism here and that
which would happen when we
studied linear differential
equations.
Let's suppose for
the sake of argument
that I want to find all points x
comma y that map into the point
1 comma 2 in the uv plane.
Essentially, what I want is
a particular solution here.
I would like to find one point
that maps into 1 comma 2.
And my claim is that knowing
the null space, once I know one
such point, I know them all.
Well, one point that maps into 1
comma 2 trivially is 0 comma 1.
Namely, 0 plus 1 is 1, and
twice 0 plus twice 1 is 2.
So 0, 1 is mapped into 1
comma 2 by the mapping f bar.
Now the question is, what other
points map into 1 comma 2?
And the answer is it's every
point on the straight line
which passes through 0 comma
1 and is parallel to the line
x plus y equals 0.
In other words,
the line x plus y
equals 1 is the line which
maps into the point 1 comma 2
under the mapping f bar.
And the easiest way to see this,
I would say, is vectorially.
Pick any point on this line.
Look at it as a vector.
That vector is the sum
of these two vectors.
This vector, being a
member of the null space,
is mapped into--
I'm sorry.
I don't want to do it this way.
I'd rather do it-- excuse me.
I'd rather do it this way.
I want to utilize the fact
that I know that this vector is
mapped into this vector.
So I'll break down this vector
into components this way.
I'll take one component
like this and one like this.
You see, this component here is
indeed the same as this vector
because these two
lines are parallel.
So therefore, f of this is
f of this plus f of this.
By linearity, that's f
of this plus f of this.
This being a vector in the
null space maps into 0,
so the image is just whatever
f of this happens to be.
You see the idea again?
Call this vector,
if you will, alpha.
Call this vector here beta.
f of alpha plus
beta is f of alpha,
which is 0, because alpha
is in the null space,
plus f of beta, which
is just 1 comma 2.
Again, I think I've made
too much of a mountain out
of a molehill, not because
this isn't important,
but because you will recall
back in our block four
treatment of linear equations,
linear algebraic equations,
we discussed things like this.
And I don't want to
get too deeply involved
in reviewing the details.
What I am interested
in seeing is
that you see the structure of
what a null space really is.
And by the way,
let's continue on
with what the properties
of a linear transformation
happen to be.
Let's leave this go
for the time being.
That's enough in
terms of examples.
Let's go on with the properties.
Our fourth property is that
if V is a vector space,
and we pick a particular
basis, u1 up to un,
then V is neatly determined.
I say "neatly determined" by
its effect on the basis vectors
u1 up to un.
What I mean by neatly
determined is the following.
Let's do a specific example.
Suppose for the sake of
argument that n is 2.
Let's look at V, which has
as its basis u1 and u2.
Pick any vector little v and
v. Relative to u1 and u2,
v has a unique representation
x1u1 plus x2u2.
f of v by the linear
property of f-- f
being a linear transformation--
is simply what? x1 f
of u1 plus x2 f of u2.
And notice that once we know
what f does to u1 and u2,
we now know what it does to
every vector in the space.
Namely, you see, to
find what f does to V,
we simply look at
the same vector as V,
only with u1 and u2 replaced
by f of u1 and f of v2.
And by the way,
because we can do this,
it implies that
linear transformations
may be represented also
very conveniently in terms
of matrix notation.
And I think that both of these
last two remarks, 4 and 5,
can be best illustrated
in terms of an example.
Let me first give you a
fairly abstract example
so that you see the terminology.
And then I'll make
this more concrete.
And the concrete example will be
our finale for today's lesson.
But first of all, by
means of an example--
example number 4.
Again, let V be a
two-dimensional space
with u1 and u2 as a basis.
Let's assume now for
the sake of argument
that the linear transformation
f maps V into V itself--
in other words, that V and
W are equal in this case,
just for the sake of argument.
Now, what did I just say?
I said before that
the transformation
is uniquely determined
once we know what it does
to each element of a basis.
What does f do to u2 and u2?
Well, since f is
mapping V into V,
and since this implies
that every vector in V
is going to be with respect
to a coordinate system u1,
u2, what I do know is that
whatever f of u1 and f of u2
are, they are linear
combinations of the basis
vectors of V u1 and u2.
So let's say for the sake
of argument that f of u1
is this linear
combination. f of u2
combination, where we're
using the usual double subscript
notation that seems to indicate
a matrix treatment coming up.
Well, let me show you
now what happens next.
Let's suppose we again
pick our arbitrary vector
and fix it-- some
arbitrary vector
V in our space V. Let's suppose
that relative to u1 and u2,
that vector v is x1u1 plus x2u2.
Well, we just saw that
f of v must therefore
be x1 f of u1 plus x2 f of u2.
But now, we know what f
of u1 and f of u2 look
like explicitly as linear
combinations of u1 and u2.
And therefore, simply by
substituting these expressions
for f of u1 and f of u2
in here, leaving again
the details for you
to verify, I find
that relative to a
2-tuple notation, where
we're using u1 and u2 as our
basis vectors, that f of v
is x1a11 plus x2a21
comma x1a12 plus x2a22.
Now, this, at first
glance, may not
seem to suggest a matrix to you.
But at second
glance, hopefully it
will, namely, if I look at
the matrix a11, a21, a12, a22.
And notice, by the way, now,
a very important subtlety
that's come up here.
In the past, the
matrix has always
been written a11, a12, a21,
a22 to match the coefficients
as they occur in these
expressions, here.
But notice, I know what
the answer has to be.
It has to be this.
All I'm saying is if you look
at this particular matrix,
this is what?
A11, x1 plus a21, x2.
And if you want the matrix to
represent the right 2-tuple,
it has to be written this way.
By the way, this is
a two-row matrix.
To make the thing come
out exactly right,
I simply take the
transpose of this.
In other words, notice that
this, without the transpose,
comes out to be two
rows and one column,
where this is the first
row, this is the second row.
To make this look exactly right,
I put the transpose in here.
By the way, remember
that we have already
seen that to take the transpose
of the product of two matrices
A, B, it's B
transpose A transpose.
So the transpose would be what?
You transpose this, which
is x1, x2, and multiply that
by the transpose of this,
which is a11, a12, a21, a22.
In other words, if you
do want this matrix
to look exactly like the matrix
of coefficients, what we're
saying is you are going to
have to write the vector x1, x2
on the left-hand side rather
than on the right-hand side.
And by the way, that's
why in many textbooks that
deal with matrix
algebra and the like,
they always put the variable
on the left-hand side.
It's because if you put the
variable on the left-hand side,
you can identify
the matrix as it
stands with the matrix of
coefficients verbatim, here.
If you don't do
that, if you want
to write the x1,
x2 on the right,
then you have to remember
that the matrix that you're
multiplying it by has its first
column, not its first row,
representing f of u1,
and its second column
representing f of u2.
And now, let's illustrate
that by means of a still more
concrete example.
Let's again let f be a
linear transformation
that maps V into V. Again,
let's assume that V is given
in terms of a basis u1 and u2.
But let's become more concrete
now and replace the as
by specific numbers.
Let's assume, for example,
that we know that f of u1
is 3u1 plus 4u2.
f of u2 is 5u1 plus 7u2.
What we're saying now
is that by linearity, we
know exactly what f does
to every vector in V,
simply in terms of
what it does here.
Now, let's see how that works.
Let me pick an arbitrary
vector in capital V. Let's say,
for example, it's 2u1 plus u2.
According to my theory of the
previous example, what must
f of V equal?
Well, what I do is I take the
matrix whose first column has
3 and 4 as entries and
whose second column
has 5 and 7 as entries.
And I multiply that by
the column matrix 2, 1.
And to make this come
out to be a row vector,
I take the transpose of this.
And that, indeed, does
turn out to be what?
3 times 2, 5 times 1.
That adds up to 11.
4 times 2 is 8.
7 times 1 is 7.
That adds up to 15.
That's the vector 11 comma
15, relative to the basis
u1 and u2.
Again, if you
don't like the idea
of having to
transpose this, if you
want to be able to write the
matrix 3, 4, 5, 7 directly,
the way you do it is write
that matrix directly.
But now, write the vector v as
a row vector on the left side
of this matrix.
You see?
Again, I'll get the
same answer, won't I?
2 times 3 is 6.
1 times 5 is 5.
6 plus 5 is 11.
2 times 4 is 8.
1 times 7 is 7.
I get 15.
Now, whichever way I do
this, notice that f of v
is 11u1 plus 15u2.
And notice also, there
was nothing sacred
about this choice of v. I
just picked a concrete example
to show you how I can determine
what the image of any vector
v with respect to the
linear transformation f
looks like once I know
the matrix of coefficients
of f relative to
the basis u1 and u2.
By the way, in
every lecture so far
I've been coming back to
this rather difficult point
that everything seems to
depend on what basis we choose.
And the interesting
point is that whereas
a linear transformation
is defined independently
of any coordinate system,
the matrix that represents
that linear transformation
does indeed depend
on the coordinate system.
For example, let
me just say that.
The matrix of f does depend on
the basis that you've chosen.
And by means of
an example, let's
let f u1, u2, and v be the same
as in the previous exercise.
Remember what that is, now.
Now, I'm going to pick a new
basis for my vector space
v. In fact, let's call
capital V the same thing, too.
Let all this be the same as
in exercise 5, example 5.
Now, I'm going to pick a new
basis, alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Relative to u1 and u2,
alpha 1 is 2u1 plus 3u2.
Alpha 2 is u1 plus u2.
Since these are not
constant multiples of one
another, alpha 1 and alpha
2 are linearly independent.
Because they're
linearly independent,
they form a basis
because they are what?
The dimension of V is 2.
And so any set of two
linearly independent vectors
in a two-dimensional space
will be a basis for that space.
So I now have a new basis
for V, alpha 1 alpha 2.
By the way, in the same way
that I can express the alphas
in terms of the us, I can invert
this by any method that I wish
and show that the
us can be expressed
in terms of the
alphas in particularly
in this particular manner.
What this means now, of
course, is that V is still
the same vector space.
But I can view it as being with
respect to the basis alpha 1,
alpha 2.
But it's the same vector space
that I had back in example 5,
when I was viewing this with
respect to the basis u1 and u2.
Now the thing that
comes up now is can I
convert everything
from example 5
into the language of the alphas?
For example, we knew in example
5 that v was 2u1 plus u2.
But now, knowing what u1
and u2 look like in terms
of the alphas, I simply
make this substitution,
replacing u1 and u2
by what they look
like in terms of the alphas.
And I conclude that in terms of
the alphas, v is minus alpha 1
plus 4 alpha 2.
In other words, notice that
v is the 2-tuple minus 1
comma 4 relative to the
basis alpha 1, alpha 2.
But if the 2-tuple 2 comma
1 relative to u1 and u2 is
the basis--
but that we already knew
from the previous lecture
that this was the case,
that the 2-tuple depended
on the basis that was chosen.
But now, I'd like to show
you that the matrix also
depends on the basis chosen.
Well, how do we
write f of v relative
to alpha 1 and alpha 2?
According to my general
theory, all I have to know
is what alpha 1 and
alpha 2 get mapped into.
And then I'm home free.
In other words, I would like
to know what f of alpha 1
and f of alpha 2
look like, but now
as linear combinations
of alpha 1 and alpha 2.
All right, how do I do this?
How do I express f of
alpha 1 and f of alpha 2
as linear combinations
of alpha 1 and alpha 2?
Well, from the previous
example, the easiest thing to do
is to express f of
alpha 1 and f of alpha 2
in terms of u1 and u2.
Namely, f of alpha 1 is what?
The matrix relative to
u1 and u2 is 3, 5, 4, 7.
Alpha 1 written in u1 and u2
components is 2u1 plus 3u2.
So f of alpha 1 is the
2-tuple 21 comma 29,
where this is
relative to u1 and u2.
In other words, f of
alpha 1 is 21u1 plus 29u2.
We know what alpha 1 and alpha
2 look like in terms of alpha 1
and alpha 2.
We just were talking about that.
Leaving the details to
you, replacing u1 and u2
by what they're equal to in
terms of alpha 1 alpha 2,
we see that f of alpha 1 is
8 alpha 1 plus 5 alpha 2.
We have now, you see,
expressed f of alpha 1
as a 2-tuple relative
to alpha 1 and alpha 2.
In a similar way, f of alpha 2
is given by this, which, again,
replacing u1 and
u2 by what they're
equal to in terms of the
alphas, turns out to be this.
So I now know the matrix
of f in terms of what
it does to alpha 1 and alpha 2.
In fact, what will
that matrix do?
Writing it in terms of
the transposed idea here,
the first column of my
matrix will be 8, 5.
The second column will be 3, 2.
So the matrix now
of f is 8, 3, 5, 2.
I multiply that by the vector v,
which as we just saw over here,
is minus 1 comma 4.
If I carry out this
operation, I have what?
Minus 8 plus 12, which is 4,
minus 5 plus 8, which is 3.
So f of v is now
the 2-tuple 4 comma
3 relative to the
basis alpha 1, alpha 2.
In other words, f of v is
4 alpha 1 plus 3 alpha 2.
And remembering that
alpha 1 was 2u1 plus 3u2,
and that alpha 2 was u1 plus
u2, I can now as a check
convert this into us.
And I then find what?
What is this?
8 plus 3 is 11.
12 plus 3 is 15.
f of v is, indeed,
11u1 plus 15u2,
which does check with our
result of the example--
what number was it?
Example 5, the previous example,
where we did the same problem
in terms of the us.
And what I want
you to see is this.
Obviously, v is a fixed vector.
f is a fixed linear
transformation.
So f of v must be
the same vector,
no matter what the basis is.
But in terms of one basis, f
of v is the 2-tuple 4 comma 3.
In terms of another basis,
it's the 2-tuple 11 comma 15.
In terms of one basis,
f is represented
by the matrix 8, 3, 5, 2.
In terms of another
basis, f is represented
by the matrix 3, 5, 4, 7.
So what you see, indeed,
is nothing more than this--
that there are two
difficult problems
that we have to deal with.
One problem, which
is relatively easy,
once you get the
basic ideas down,
is the fact that linear
transformations have nothing
to do with the basis.
You see?
It's defined for a vector space.
But the difficult point
is that in many cases
we are dealing with
a specific basis.
In the middle of a problem,
we change from one basis
to another.
Consequently, the
basis that represents
the linear transformation
will, in general, change,
as we go from one
representation to another.
And this is where a lot of
computational difficulty
seems to creep in.
Again, I will hammer this
home during the exercises.
But for now, what I hope you
have gotten out of this lecture
is the overall view of what
a linear transformation means
and how, in terms
of vector spaces,
the concept of linearity
finds a very nice unified home
to live in.
At any rate then, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.